more practical aspects and of course
it's tough in Rapid chess especially
when the clocks are low sometimes you
just play moves to scare your opponent
to randomize things and that doesn't
necessarily affect the game so it's
interesting to keep an eye on those
stats the lower the number the better
but uh either way we're off here we go
aim just rapid has started yeah and it's
the Spanish the Royal Oak has opening uh
not a surprise Lawrence Sri Lanka no I
mean we see this opening so many times I
mean it seems to be the Mainstay of the
top players but uh this particular poor
move isn't so popular on this level I
have to say it's very very popular
um in players around my strength so you
often see it in in women's tournaments I
mean a lot of my colleagues play this
line yeah it's it makes sense you're
just getting ready to fionkato the black
bishop and we saw Eric kind of stare up
at the sky being like what do I do here
of course you've seen this move before
but he wouldn't have studied it recently
most likely and nariditsky is quite
famous for his Blitz chess his bullet
chess he just wants to survive the
European usually and normally he's his
strengths light in the middle game and
end game so will Eric go really direct
wait here we go white can push report in
the center exploding things open this is
the direct way because often there are
exchanges
immediately now White's Bishop can come
out where I can simply recapture the
pawn in the center okay he attacks the
black queen if you'd want to play more
slowly Eric he would have just castled
the work King maybe slowly stepped
forward in the center but now after a
trailer Bishops usually there we go
another exchange and white has regained
the pawn still very theoretical position
this has all been seen many times before
and this is the first real choice for
white either white can Castle queenside
this is one of the most popular moves
but that that would allow black to
capture the White Knight or you step
back with the white knight and maintain
a good Pawn structure yeah you're right
David many many games in the database
and uh I'm guessing now that
the choice for white is still very much
there you know white can I actually step
back the queen if she's attacked and
still there is the option of perhaps
cosplaying the king to the right or to
the left if you can get very ambitious
so in terms of chest style who do you
think this uh this position will favor
single favor Eric I've actually had this
position with black a few times I've
done very poorly from this position yet
C5 is is standard queen E3 this has been
played many many times why does
effectively got a porn majority on the
on the center and then on the king side
white tends to follow up with F3 here
and probably will Castle on the queen
side as well and but black is very solid
so it's um I'm slightly surprised by
this opening by by Danielle because his
stuff he's got a swashbuckling style
really he he's he's a very talented
tactician and with the two kings on the
queen side probably then well we have
one of those very entertaining starts to
the tournament
normally Kai is when the kings are
actually on other sides of the board on
opposite sides of the board when the
kings are on opposite sides then you can
start throwing your pawns down the board
because your king isn't exposed
um
you know something like this exactly so
if the white king goes to to the right
side to the king side you can start
throwing those Queen side pawns down the
board to open up lines so I'm very
curious to see uh where uh Eric actually
can we still see him Castle to the king
side he both options like if this bishop
goes back to E6 both options are very
legitimate here actually and the most
ambitious because era Daniel's King is
on the queen side would be king side
yeah I think so I think that's a fair a
fair assessment but ambitious but also a
bit risky right yes because now black if
you do Castle this side black does have
a ready-made plan later on yes pushing
this Pawn forward and trying to go for
the white king could it could even do it
straight away but that's it yeah that's
very that's very ambitious but it's not
completely it's not complete and uh
anyway the kings are moved to the same
side my My Vibe is that so Eric is going
to look for getting an advantage in the
later stages of the game and I'm just
basing it on my knowledge of the pawn
structure because if you take a look at
the pawn structure especially in the mid
in the middle on the right side you'll
see that white has an extra pawn and
black has uh what Beth Harmon hated
those double pawns and those pawns are
no good you know they're kind of almost
worth one they control squares but
that's about it so it's all going to be
about whites using that extra Pawn they
do control squares around the king
though yeah are they good for protection
you know they're good Defenders but uh
you know they're not good for creating
past pawns which in the end game in the
later stages of the game you need your
pawns to mobilize forward yeah so if you
can imagine all of the pieces
disappearing apart from the Kings and
pawns then Black's four here will never
really beat whites three because you
can't create past born but White's four
on this side they can definitely beat
blacks three because they are connected
so white would easily if the Pieces come
off the board just be able to start
pushing everything forward and white
would be winning but of course a long
long way to go before that happens
narodeski won't trade off all of the
pieces he'll leave at least a few things
on the board and uh like you say kayak
Black's King is pretty safe in the
meantime okay he just sure shows up his
Queen side he just makes sure all these
pawns protect each other and yeah it's
it's going to be a maneuvering game for
the time being Eric now getting ready to
try and trade off all the Rooks
both these players are uh just over 2600
on the ratings in classical chess are
they very
equally good both in streaming and in
chess
both super Grandma for learning
streaming yeah yeah
your favorite streamer among these two
um I I like Dania because he does
fantastic impressions
if you've seen that um did someone on
our show last year yeah yeah I think you
know Kasparov he can do Kasparov
napomnishi kramnik uh he's he's he tried
to do you David but it was I I pulled
him up I said Daniel listen uh you've
got to work on the English accent a
little bit I haven't heard that one yeah
I have to say if we have it now for an
interview I'm trying to hear that I
agree especially if he's been refining
it yeah yeah and obvious obviously Eric
is uh is the streaming partner with your
opponent in the chess boxing fight um on
Hamilton yeah yeah the chess bras are
they talking about the chess boxing oh
yeah all the time yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
you know Eric is uh I imagine he's a
man's
shoulder to cry on
his moral support I don't know but I
know they're excited I think we'll talk
about that later but uh yeah uh no
they're both fantastic streamers and
fantastic Grandmasters first they are
Grandmasters and then they are streamers
that's important to say
and a set of Works have left the board I
love Lawrence's trash talk in there it's
how a Brit does it
and it's very uncommon in chess right
the the trash talking but she has boxing
very common yeah well you know in the
boxing world yeah I'm trash talking I
like that one the best element ever yeah
but um yeah I don't see why it can't be
yeah an element in chess boxing yeah I
think in chess boxing it's it's
perfectly acceptable and should be
encouraged
um yeah in chess in general we never
really had
the rivalries if I think of the
rivalries of the past it hasn't been
trash truck it's been a lot more subtle
yeah worth trash talking that's true
noises I remember he came up with some
classic lines
my opponent's name means fish
so he plays like a fish I think he might
even said coldfish I think I've even cup
or a cup
but uh yeah I mean there were some
instances Kasparov in short he was
saying oh this his name is short and it
will be short as in he'll win yeah
um there's some instances I guess as
well in in the US there are lots of uh
kind of Chess and Parks yeah with the
hustlers and they trash talk big time
um so there is some precedent but
well I mean you know the pure form of
Chess we it's it's a Regal game it's a
gentleman League game so I think cut
toning down the trash talking chess is
actually quite fine but when it comes to
boxing
No Holds Barred right basically let's
just I mean you kind of need it right to
be motivated to punch someone in the
face
yeah yeah yeah yes
um also uh trying to sell a lot of
tickets yeah you know because that's
normally part of the the boxing formula
yeah so yeah but this game is very cool
we've gone off to a very quiet start
here no they're not they haven't got the
pitchforks out now this is all a bit of
tap dancing Daniel seems a little
nervous even hiding in his shirt well
the thing is though you know it is a
very quiet position but uh Daniel does
Have To Tread accurately because the
long game is brewing you know it's that
advantage that we talked about you know
it's building and the more pieces that
get traded off the more things that
Dania doesn't do then uh the more
pressing this extra Pawn in the middle
will be so I I think he will be feeling
nervous you know that's the thing with
chess you know it's not just you know
swords drawn and swords meets in the
middle of the board you know sometimes
you have the long game and you have all
this nervous tension and yeah he doesn't
look comfortable meanwhile Eric just
looks like he's in Yoda mode you know
it's totally Zen yeah we should mention
that narodinski doesn't play maybe as
much over the board compared to Eric
nowadays Eric played for example the
Olympiad he played the European Club cup
just last week so he's
he's kind of in the zone he's played
himself into a decent form but
naroditsky mainly streams mainly
commentates nowadays so maybe just the
five minutes that he spent up to this
point that's just kind of getting back
in the mindset of kind of playing a slow
strategic game most of his chess games
online are Blitz and bullet games and
he's one of the fastest
um out there one of the fastest hands in
the west with the mouse so even if he
gets in time trouble narrative will
still be very very good but yeah a bit
strange to see him think also to me it's
a bit strange that Eric kept the Rooks
on the board because we thought uh with
this last move sidestepping a trade
because we thought swapping off pieces
would favor white long term I have
because of those double black pawns yeah
interesting decision by Eric keeping
some tension rather than just going
straight for kind of that mass equation
simplification trading and working with
a better Pawn structure so okay now
risky will move eventually but just
coming up with a plan now so why did
Eric then keep the Rook on what is his
plan now
it's mysterious maybe that's why
narulitsky uh is a bit confused okay the
king just sidesteps always a good idea
if you Castle on the long side tuck your
king nearer the corner just to make sure
it's safe
um yeah I'm wondering what Eric's Rook
is doing maybe he just wants to support
his Central Pawn pushing forward later I
don't think you want to rush you don't
want to put your pawns on dark squares
and give blacks Bishop the only Bishop
on the board control over the light
squares but okay big threat on the board
uh Eric's night now jumping into the
center if that Knight could jump to the
C6 square that would be a check and what
we call a family Fork the White Knight
was trying to Fork the king the black
queen and the black Rook but Naruto stop
that
now what do you think Knight takes
bishop or just keep that Knight in the
center yeah I think F4 yeah exactly
That's The Logical move it's like it
looks pretty good actually in the middle
of the board right now it does and uh
then white is potentially threatening as
well to take some extra space and I
start advancing those pawns on the right
and uh there we can see a selfie from me
mega patil and yeah we love it when
everyone at home joins in the fun and
the action and sensors the Selfies shows
us where they're watching the show from
and you can do that by tweeting us using
the hashtag chess champ and we will try
and feature them on the show and uh
there you can see Daniel's Bishops I
takes a step backwards it's not good
when uh he's being forced to sound the
retreat
yeah I mean you're right it's very
passive but I quite like these Bishop
Maneuvers and this kind of Knight versus
Bishop pattern white tonight in the
center and Black's Bishop on the top of
the board it's not clear does the Knight
dominate the bishop or does the bishop
dominate the Knight
the black Bishop still has long-term
potential but
it does take a while for uh nardisky now
to try and get rid of that beast in the
center of the board Eric's stepping the
White Queen back hinting maybe that the
white Queen's actually going to go to
the edge of the board to the H4 Square
just create a nasty pin against the
Black Knight
yeah it's a bit uncomfortable just
temporarily at least for naraditski
feels like he's been overthinking a bit
and retreating his pieces which isn't
great
that black king move that I praised
actually the black king is within range
of the White Knight it's not ideal
what do you think Lawrence doesn't need
to worry about or I as I said I'm kind
of surprised Daniel went for this
opening I don't think it suits him
stylistically whatsoever he he likes the
dynamism in positions he's he he's an
extremely talented calculator and these
are positions where I'm not saying he
can't you don't get to 2600 Plus without
being able to do this but shuffling
around and not doing very much that's
something David you're great at for
example
um and I mean that as a real compliment
but for Dania
I I don't see it as one of his big
strengths so H5 not in love with with
age five again more weaknesses long term
really tough positions because I've
stopped white pushing importance forward
and that right side doesn't stop the
White Queen maybe going to the edge of
the board lining up on a diagonal
um yeah like you said you just got to
play to your strengths and
um I mean nordiski can do everything
he's very good at that but when we've
seen him kind of put his head in his
hands he's clearly trying to calculate
but this is not the type of position
where you can calculate your way out of
trouble you can't really find any
forcing lines unless your opponent
initiates
yeah yeah I'm expecting Eric to maybe
even just start pushing
um the white G Pawn can step forward two
squares the White Queen can move
there are ways to create threats yeah
and I'm just gonna
take the time to draw the attention to
the white king this is safe because the
reason I'm asking this is because in my
last two games I kid you not it was all
to do with King safety I was the one
attacking but I never took that time out
to make a grand master move
what do you think is it safe in that
square or
should it take some right precautionary
measures and tuck it into the corner
just in case
yeah normally I would say always tuck
your king in the corner if you've cast a
queen side or at least Chuck it one
square just like black is done but
White's King can't be attacked by a
bishop ever black doesn't have dark
Square Bishops Black's pieces are far
far away from ever launching Landing a
check
hmm yeah it feels like maybe some more
urgent stuff to be done yeah but I
wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised ivank
if Eric does that over the next few
moves at least at some point the bar has
definitely been finishing up for Eric he
still has more than 12 minutes on the
clock so would you say it's looking
really good for Eric in this first game
promising start for him and like Lauren
said opening wise Eric's actually very
predictable he nearly always plays the
Spanish opening he nearly always goes
for lines that he can control and that
he won't get into into direct kind of
confrontation with uh with the opponent
so it just suits him down to the ground
yeah I mean these guys must have faced
each other what thousands of times you
think online in Blitz and bullet games
but
uh it leaves time difference hundreds
definitely yeah
but rapid chess is a different Cutler
fish and this is why Eric is taking a
bit of time out now you notice both the
players they stop when they're planning
and okay a retreat I love that night
yeah I loved it where it stood
and the bishop now comes out uh yeah
it's surprising the bishop was kind of
controlled on a passive Square now it's
active attacking the white porn Center
and
I don't think we really want to touch
those Pawns in the center they will give
black species some squares if they step
forward
trench ah yeah it feels like Eric maybe
just not backing himself to start
creating those threats yeah maybe he was
just lost for a plan you know he'd just
done all the peace maneuvering because I
don't like what he's done treating the
night and now the queen comes to the H4
square and now the Black Knight is
pinned
yeah okay this was Eric's plan the Black
Knight only really has one safe square
if it wants to retreat it has to protect
its Queen
this tension I mean is there a threat
for white I don't really see a direct
threat
just kind of causing some discomfort I
guess uh with the White Queen on that
diagonal
that's yeah still very cagey it's like
in boxing when they're just kind of
eyeing each other up they're just
dancing around each other at the moment
trying to land any punches necessarily
yeah will we see a knockout though in
this game is it the possession right now
does it look like a game that will end
up with a winner or something that would
be a draw
if there's going to be a winner it's
more likely to be white probably but
yeah still plenty of play left in this
one while the Queens remain on the board
narodetsky has decent chances at some
point to get active to create some
Dynamic play which Lawrence pointed out
as his Forte but if the Queen's come off
I think white has some level of some
degree of safety okay the Black Knight
does retreat offering that Queen trade
okay if Eric wants to take the risk out
he'll just swap queens and
try and play this end game if he wants
to keep more tension he'll Retreat the
White Queen but then why did you bring
her to this Square in the first place if
you're not going to
trade-off what would you guys do
I I wouldn't trade off Queens step back
um
but then again that's just my preference
I kind of feel like Eric needs to keep
the Queens on to just to put pressure on
noraditsky's position but then again I
think it's fair fair cop really anything
goes yeah narudiskey so he is a dynamic
player but he's also written some
columns some newspaper columns magazine
articles on end games so very very well
versed in the end game as well chess
historian he knows a little bit about
Chess history narrator ski so yeah I
mean Eric
it's it's unclear do you go for a
strategy where you go into an end game
against quite a famed uh endgame player
or do you do what he's just done and
keep the Queens on Ivanka was right
another Black Knight is on a bad Square
so you've gained something in that last
couple of moves do you think this is a
maybe a draw offer if the Black Knight
comes forward the queen is going to
retreat to what it's going to return to
the H4 Square
I think we'll see Eric try and repeat
initiated uh no Eric will never repeat
this position the white Queen's on a
better Square than she was earlier as
well
okay
I don't know I mean nowadayski probably
would love to repeat oh there you go
okay so if White Queen goes back where
she came from we've seen that position
before
But Eric has more choice now well he
won't he I agree I agree with you David
I don't think he will repeat the
position yeah and this must be a
prestigious game for both of these two
they are two of the lower rated players
in the tournament this is a game they
both uh need to win to hope to qualify
for The Knockout stage right definitely
but you know the thing is though with
the draw offer it does add that kind of
extra element like here I'm sure Daniel
will be thinking is he gonna repeat and
he will be wasting some time and some
energy thinking about these things and
the queen does step forward to the
diagonal but moves to the G4 Square
which to my eyes looks like an improved
version
G5 the Knight could still step back
offering a queen trade again
look sensible that's what I would do
yeah
yeah it's just really hard to evaluate
White's chances yeah
um
yeah it's a tough position it's a very
tough position
um I mean I don't see anything else
other than stepping the Black Knight
back to where it came from just again
trying to offer that Queen exchange okay
he
instead Retreats the bishop
um
okay at least The Bishop's on a safe
Square I was always I hate having pieces
undefended loose pieces and that's that
Bishop was previously vulnerable to the
white Knights so the bishop is safe
keeps the black king safe so this is
basically just a frustrating game to
play especially for Daniel because it is
it seems on you guys it's very difficult
to spot the plants but it feels like
there's something especially for white
then exactly yeah I mean again it's
White's better Pawn structure it's just
temporarily at least what is a bit more
active White's Queen really well placed
White tonight's ready to pounce
um yeah it feels like narrative is just
waiting and
one thing that we have noticed
throughout the tour
um one thing I always expected when I
was playing long games but it's really
kind of accentuated in Rapid chess is
that planning actually takes much longer
than calculating when you see the top
players calculates they see variations
bang bang like super quickly just
because every move is often forced and
it's easy to see even five ten moves
into the future if your opponent only
has one reply every time but if it's a
plan if you've got three or four
different
kind of options where to put your pieces
what type of Pawn structure to go for
what type of which piece exchange is to
make that's when they really kind of
tank and that's why we've seen
nariditski spend already eight minutes
even though nothing that dramatic has
happened so you recommend calculating
instead of planning um or the other way
around you have to do both the chests
yeah but calculation you can practice
all the top players are really natural
uh at it but calculation you can
practice you can make yourself really
quick but planning you always have to
take a time out you have to take a step
back talk yourself through the process
what do you want what's your opponent
want there's just a lot of questions so
um yeah the plates are doing the right
thing they're they're spending a lot of
time but
um it's up to Eric now how to increase
the pressure
and to find a very interesting actually
that it's
narodesky that uh refused to kind of
repeat the position refuse to retreat
the night and instead of maybe saying
let's see what you got let's see what
the big plan is Eric and I'm going to
try and Grand you out
they're both very ambitious players as
well they always play for the maximum
for the win
nariditski I've played him a few times
recently we had a short match on uh kind
of a blitz match and
there was one game I just tried to force
a draw with white because I was like
okay I've got the worst position ever
and he just never ever I mean he just
didn't let me off the hook he tried to
grind me down and normally it's the
other way around so I was uh I was very
impressed by his determination his
fighting Spirit left did I see something
on Twitter the other day David that you
were trying to set a record on leeches
for the longest game ever what was that
yeah I I played a game and my opponent
kind of blundered quite early on and I
think around move 50 he could have just
resigned I was about to make a new Queen
but he just didn't resign so I thought
okay that's punishment is due so I
thought okay let's just keep the game
going as long as possible my opponent
only had a king I had a queen a pawn and
a bishop so I kind of spent 49 moves
then I pushed a pawn 49 moves I push
another point so we got to move 300 and
then leeches just shut the game down it
said draw because apparently that's the
limit it doesn't allow me this longer
than 300 wins I was gutted I calculated
I had at least four more Pawn
did you get back the rating foreign
[Laughter]
moves I mean the longest game in world
championship history is
126 or something 130 something Magnus
said it recently yeah in 2021 300 it's
more than the double
how much time does this does this take
um that was just a rapid game so we had
10 minutes each on the clock I still had
nearly five minutes left at the end but
um yeah that's one cautionary tale don't
play with your food today
and don't play with David if you are in
a rush that too it's a nariditski
definitely not in a rush just playing a
compound move yeah
controlling some squares now the black
pawns control any squares the white
Knights want to jump into on that left
off of the board still very cagey just
yeah both players I don't think are
particularly comfortable here actually
somehow because I think they both
understand it's one of those positions
which is very close to equal and
you know you make small moves here A3
you know B3 perhaps although I'm not a
massive fan of B3
you could try G4 but
um I'm not sure the trade of Pawns
actually helps white particularly
um
yeah I could mean your Queen's kind of
in the way you want to step away now and
then push this point again but and takes
time just to kind of uh make sense of uh
Daniel's last move
I mean he yeah I mean yeah this A6 move
is there the possibility that he could
be playing in a very super ambitious
manner by actually threatening to push
the B Pawn from one step forward maybe
move it another square and uh it's there
now it's a possibility it wasn't before
yeah yeah true
um it's really fascinating how different
our minds are of anchor because I
thought okay just pushing this poor now
the king is safe you've got us an escape
Square you're controlling every Square
on your corner I didn't even consider
pushing this Pawn forward but now you
mention it yeah
um if you can destabilize this Knight
kick this night away then suddenly this
Pawn in the center is vulnerable to the
bishop and to the Knight yeah I'm not
saying I would do it right now it's uh
something in the back of my pocket that
I would bring out yeah at the right time
yeah why not before it's too late you
can push the points of people
oh very good David very good but yeah
it's tempting okay we have seen G4 on
the board so white is pushing but it's
not clear what the next move is
um okay I guess at the moment he's maybe
threatening to capture this Pawn but if
black
is the idea if uh if black captures to
take with a knight
I don't really think this is uh too
great it looks like a pin the Black
Knight can step back however defend its
Queen
unless there's an idea of trading off
the queens and somehow I don't know
going for this Pawn I don't really see
it right now but okay we have seen a
capture from naroditski so he was just
doing a bit of calculation there and
Eric wants to take you always want to
capture towards the center you want to
keep your pawns together but Knight
takes Pawn is maybe a more Dynamic
option
hmm all right the bar is slowly inching
up for Eric but it is a slow start to
the aim chess rapid most games seem to
be about equal although Magnus Carlsen
the bar is going up for him in game one
against Chucky and Mom Darwin it's also
looking very good Richard report against
Hare Krishna and Richard report I know
there's been some questions about him
playing under a different flag now he
has switched countries some federations
so he is now representing Romania used
to represent Hungary and I think he
lives in Serbia very International
Grandmaster yeah his wife is well very
strong player yeah for Serbia I think
yeah I think he lives in Serbia he lives
in Belgrade changed to Federation I
think although you can't quote me on
this I think they've moved to to um to
Bucharest aha I think so they moved to
Romania and now now they've both
switched actually okay yep so now
representing another country great news
for uh Romania Richard report is not
only a great player very entertaining
player so look forward to follow his
games as well and it looks like he's
getting a very good start against
another super strong player Hare Krishna
can't wait to see uh Richard's stats on
AIM chess because he has the most
unusual creative thoughts ever so I want
to see if the computer approves or the
computer's gonna go no accuracy porn
loss yeah exactly Skyrocket high no
maybe maybe if he's playing weird and
wonderful quirky moves I don't know how
the computer would register that I know
to the human mind it's like whoa what is
this and then 10 moves later you're like
well that one had a very deep plan but I
didn't see we will take a look at that
later when we follow Richard report now
we are following Eric and uh Daniel the
bar is back to the center what a tense
game yeah very tense and naroditski
couldn't decide where to put the black
king he brought it back towards the
center now defending his Queen again
very sensible the black queen was the
only undefended piece in Black's Camp
you're gonna guard against any tricks by
protecting your pieces and I don't know
about Eric's night Retreat somehow he's
ready to push pause in the center but
again
comes with uh kind of downsides as well
if you push the white Pawns in the
center they might be vulnerable you
might give away some squares
down to five minutes Eric down to four
minutes this one what do you think time
scramble
yeah I think they might both actually uh
enjoy a bit of a Time scramble because
they're very very good Adrenaline
Junkies yeah they're adrenaline drunkies
they're fantastic bullet players
fantastic Blitz players
um
so it wouldn't surprise me if we get a
bit of a shootout in in time trouble but
yeah it's been such a cagey game nobody
really wants to make a serious
commitment you know your your idea of
going E5 here for example yeah he's just
against the idea of pushing this pawn
and I completely understand it
um Knight F2 looks like a an on all
right move
maybe we can show you just why pushing
up that one was not as attractive as it
might look initially Lawrence so if the
pawn pushes forward where would you put
this Knight would you
think you'd probably go to D5 do you not
put it in and for example if the Queens
come off if the knights come off
we talked about this poor majority being
good but they are quite weak as well
yeah Black's Bishop can attack this Pawn
for example uh White tonight it's not
that great
you have to kind of take care of this
Pawn just in case at some point you
don't want to rush to take it the bishop
might get trapped there but uh White
might lose some time blacks Kings also
near the center
looks like a Berlin end game uh which
does we know has a very good very solid
reputation for black
and okay uh white instead retreating
unclear where that night's going just
defending his Pawn I guess in the center
of the board and passing the move back
to Daniel and I'm I just have a feeling
he's going to maybe push his Bishop to
the square put his King on the Square
just kind of wait and sit and
there we go it's just a very norajitsky
type of move that one is the type of
move you play when you don't want to
commit any other pieces don't want to
commit to any plan next move your
advances King just to a slightly safer
Square
and the weight goes on what do you
prefer in this game the the bishop and
the Knight or the two knights
a very good question I think
I'm struggling to come up with an answer
just because they both have pros and
cons the knights they both look good but
at the moment they don't have anywhere
effective to jump into I'm very biased
because I love Bishops in general but I
normally prefer them as a pair here
Black's Bishop is
quite decent though putting some
pressure on the center
um I actually like Black's Pawn
structure now these pawns cover the dark
squares this bishop covers the light
squares so um you just kind of control
everything right now but
yeah it's it's hard to say the knights
if they can find out posts later on they
will be potentially quite strong
all right taking under three minutes he
spent a lot of time now on these last
moves
yeah and it's still not very clear what
his plan is because at some point he is
gonna have to commit and to have to
advance something and uh well treating
the queen does indicate that he wants to
as David's showing to push the G Pawn to
attack the Knight but is that even so
great I don't know I mean I must admit
you know look at White's position
there's no Harmony I mean you mentioned
none of the nights are on good circuits
they've got no active roles they don't
have any posts to string forward to and
yeah and you know me I I've got the back
of my mind this uh porn Advance yes but
okay no I wanted to do it after a while
I've been I've been watching and
learning from uh David both Davids and
Daniel and I'm thinking yeah yeah
improve your king fast and then
yeah and then you start taking out
exactly because I mean it's a Blitz game
now though it's three minutes against
three minutes maybe the moment is coming
Ivanka maybe you just go for it just
start posing different uh different
questions different problems for your
opponent
when do you change the pace of the game
when do you go a bit more direct rather
than just sitting and waiting neither
player wants to do that forever
and I am noticing in another game
Magnus Carlson the bar was over to
Magnus aside but it has shifted to
Shakira's side are we getting a little
bit of a shocking start in that one
very good for Mama jarov just took a
peek over
I can do that yeah you mentioned report
being full of surprises uh mama jorov is
another one David Anton they've all got
these Styles where they can surprise you
they can beat anyone on their day well
we also have the biggest surprise chest
surprise I think I've ever seen in
history was when nordeback Abdul sotorov
won the world rapid
championships I mean who would have
thought that was out of the blue 17
years old at the time yeah I mean he's
promising but to I think he beat Magnus
he beat Carolina he beat napomishi in
the playoffs yeah
how do you I mean beat one of these guys
let alone all of them in a row like I'll
do Satora did
uh just last year last December yeah
and uh later on only a couple months ago
he led Uzbekistan to the Olympiad goal I
mean watch a player
been a bit of a oh it's been a decent
decent yeah yeah
well Champion world team jet well we're
Olympic champion it's it's not a bad
year he's uh he's a phenomenal talent
and I've spoken to a lot of top GMS
about him who've even quite a long time
ago said that there was something very
special about him
um his rating doesn't quite reflect it
yet it's quite interesting he's still
not you would kind of expect him to be
27 30 27 40 and in a classical he's not
there yet
still very young is that because of
covet just two years not playing over
the board I think partially but I think
actually he's just waiting for
invitations to Big tournaments and we
got your move I know and I feel like
I've won lucky on the chess Bingo once
more look at that I've been raving about
this move now for quite a while I
probably would have done it 10 moves ago
but it's now better late than never and
provoked Eric into finally taking some
action as well so finally belatedly the
players are doing something and the game
is holding up
okay the Black Knight under attack I I
am starting to like black more and more
though like it feels like white has been
unsuccessfully shuffling not really much
progress made even this porn with you
put a knight on H5 uh here as black as
would be the standard procedure the
Knight is not out of bounds there it it
hits I'm kind of surprised by Knight D7
but perhaps Daniel's also thinking it
can reroute to B6 in some positions
would you put the Knight on H5 David I
think those arguments to be made for
both I think it's a matter of taste
Lawrence now like you said the night is
going this way he's just planted it and
the black king now super safe with these
pieces but also hinting to come in and
this one is very weakening for white
hate this move well if I play C4 here
what's going on exactly and he's played
it the queen is coming in suddenly and
White's King which was safe for so long
is no longer
um feeling so good about life and it's
not just uh the king that's in trouble I
mean we have to also mention the
unsupported Pawn in the middle of the
board if
I mean it's just one tiny poor move from
evicting the Knight on C3 which is in a
very important Defender
Suddenly It's happening and look at
White's Queen what is this piece doing
on the side of the board he's blocked in
his own Queen
um it was active for so long now it's
not participating this night not great
either and yeah I mean it is clear plan
this is just over right I mean
objectively yeah I think it's just done
because uh you know Queen A3 check is a
threat but also if you played a move
like
Knight F to D1 it's not a particularly
Pleasant move to play but just to try
and get the queen back you run into a
very quick B4
and then your E4 Pawn drops and your
position collapses this is actually
total collapse here and Eric was just
not able you know one of the greatest
skills in chess the what David can do
what uh you know some really top
Grandmasters can do is in those kinds of
positions is do nothing very well and if
you do nothing very badly like Eric has
done in this game you can get punished
and fair play to dania I mean he
he was very calm he didn't rush okay
this move Queen G3 is not going to save
the day for Eric in my opinion
how do we finish this off here can you
dive in the first one that I think of is
Jack Jack yeah check and uh there it
comes and uh the King has to move to the
side of the board and now I mean it's so
tempting just to push one Pawn forward
yeah you've got to be slightly careful
your queen uh is uh running out of
squares but she's still very active the
White Knight has to drop back you can
push this Pawn forward for example the
White Knight does guard against any
checkmates but it looks like it's
hanging by a thread I guess white can
continue defending here another idea
would be to just capture this Pawn but
you have to be a bit careful again and
there might be some tactics
there would be a pin so black still has
some tricks to dodge I'm gonna I'm gonna
Channel my inner earvenger here and
you know uh Ari the a porn
um as Simon might say uh can we just
start throwing A5 A4 down the board and
just rip open the cover of that white
king you're right there's there's no
rush okay I love this one Lawrence
actually yeah pushing forward
um white screen still takes an age to
get anywhere decent but okay he's
dropped his Queen back uh naroditsky and
maybe some threats on the board along
this diagonal using a pin the white Rook
moves up in Lawrence you lean forward it
feels like something's going wrong for
white it feels so loose Daniel not
finding the The Knockout though right
these are kind of slightly uh
he's nervous I think yeah nervous moves
yeah yeah first game of the tournament
it's understandable and also if you take
a look at the clock times both players
nearing the one minute Mark you know you
you often don't want to commit to such a
brutal strategies to commit all
strategies when you have not so much
time on the clock and uh well we see him
just attack The Rook I don't think this
is a bad move I think black has still
got the overwhelming position
just hasn't finished off the game they
are both entering known territory though
bullet that's right and I've watched
many of Daniel's streams and often his
strategy is to just kind of pose
problems to the opponent force them to
burn some time on the clock just
calculating just trying to survive so it
feels like as Lauren said he's not been
the most direct he's not going for a
knockout but he's just asking Eric's
difficult questions on every turn and
the white Knights now are completely
stuck black switches angle
love this move this is a lovely move no
threat but white always has to be
careful of that Rook coming in now
um you know if that Rook ever can come
in with a check on the first rank it's
going to be curtains the game over and
it's the kind of move and uh I have to
say I have to quote from our dear friend
Simon
discombobulates your opponent
so confusing yeah exactly it's like oh
so I didn't realize that line existed
okay and The Rook does take a step back
so yeah earlier she's talking about the
art of doing nothing and I saw this
great quote recently it was like the
tactician knows what to do when there's
something to do but the strategist uh
knows when what to do and when there's
nothing to do and now you've got to
actually do something that's the that's
the thing you've got to switch mindset
okay the white knight in the center your
a pawn push is coming if you like a
little bit later than I would have liked
because white has actually been able to
rearrange his pieces in in quite a
decent way here black is still better
but I'm not convinced I I don't know how
much better now
um
at least for example okay the bar going
down but worse comes to the worst white
can swap off the black Bishop wait so I
can go and take it and
I don't think you're gonna get
checkmated there's just not enough
material left so okay he does swap off
sorry maybe there was no rush with that
but yeah I was thinking about the move
Queen over to C3 there first but okay
Eric trying to get some stability on the
dark squares here makes perfect sense
but uh
yes why king is not safe and yeah we
talked about that pawn structure earlier
black having more pawns on the left but
you won't create any past pawns but you
have more protection for your king so
black has three pawns on the queen side
white has two you have more Pawn
protection on the other side of the
board it's kind of irrelevant right now
but uh Eric being very sneaky here you
know capturing
the pawn on B3 with this particular move
and uh that's an unexpected move and uh
Daniel responds by putting his Rook on
the seventh on the second row punches
um I don't know I still feel this is a
big fight and uh the white Brook now
eyeing up the black queen
okay the one this white Rook Shuffle I
don't really see the threat yes there's
a pin now but Black's Queen can simply
move I would have rushed to kick that
black Rook out of uh out of White's camp
okay black queen does sidestep maybe now
is the time just to kind of go not sure
about this queen move okay anyway this
has achieved the big mission The Rook
has been kicked back but the White
Knight now has to jump forward has to
find some active posts it's not great is
it no he's lined up on the same diagonal
as the black king with this move there's
kind of a semi threat of pushing what's
E Pawn forward with a discovered check
but uh okay I'm expecting Naruto to just
move his Queen
black queen which way is she gonna go is
she gonna dive back in towards the white
king and she's just gonna stay in the
center
and uh the players now with seconds left
on the clock 44 seconds for Eric
um meanwhile it's now coming under 30
seconds for Daniel narodetsky and uh all
right on the board what happened
draw what did you like it it looks
anti-climax it looks like Eric offered a
drawn narutitsuki said yes
wow just as things were heating up as
well yeah yeah we were finally getting
excited about this game and uh we do
have a result it is a draw strange Eric
Hansen he just runs off but uh Daniel
still sitting by the computer